it looks like war but this is the sound
of Africa's newest peacekeeping effort
morale is high the soldiers come from
all over the continent to learn how to
work together as a single effective
response unit it's a major challenge to
integrate forces with vastly different
experience financial backing and
language but it appears to be working
here at the Mozambique and military's
camp visiting South African soldiers are
getting to know their counterparts major
recent asou is commander of the
Mozambique and contingent for the
exercise the meaning of this exercise is
to train our troops and we can now say
that these troops are ready ready to be
deployed wherever and whenever they are
needed the forces main tasks are to
prevent atrocities and bring peace to
troubled areas while upholding the law
Africa is increasingly destabilized by
growing extremist movements like Boko
Haram in West Africa and al-shabaab in
the Horn of Africa these groups are
threatening fragile States and driving
regional instability poppy Kariba from
Ghana is the exercise coordinator at
Central Command this exercise is
teaching the military police and
civilians on the force how to deal with
asymmetric warfare terrorism and
humanitarian crisis so it is presumed
that this exercise have actually been
able to stabilize the situation based
upon crimes against humanity and now we
are leading into issues of long-term
reconstruction efforts responding to
crises is not always a question of
military readiness you can have a force
as ready as it may be but if the
political will is not there you will not
be able to deploy the force in a timely
manner the African Union has already
deployed into war zones like Somalia one
of the most dangerous conflicts in the
world track record of Africa
Union Peace missions is quite good
because they are willing to deploy where
the United Nations is not willing to
deploy doing the job with minimum
resources at great risk of their own
lives when it comes to saving lives
these soldiers know every minute counts